Tucker Carlson's transformation from
Islamophobe to Islamo
over the past 2 years is even more
shocking than Muhammad's transformation
from bi-curious to 100% gay on the night
of Al Zuk.
In his most recent tongue bath of all
things Islam, Tucker declares that
mocking Muhammad's religion is evil and
immoral. Islam should never be mocked by
anyone.
In context, Tucker is responding to
Trump's post from a few days ago where
the president promised bad things for
Iran. Trump said,
"Tuesday will be power plant day and
bridge day all wrapped up in one in
Iran. There will be nothing like it.
Open the censored straight you crazy
bees." I still don't know if that's a
curse word or not. "Or you'll be living
in hell. Just watch. Praise be to Allah.
President Donald J. Trump."
Now, this post was a bit weird even by
Trump's standards and Tucker does raise
some important concerns, but I'm going
to address most of Tucker's response in
a separate video. Here, I want to take a
closer look at Tucker's claim that no
one should ever mock Islam because
that's the clip that was shared over and
over and over on X. Let's have a look.
So, Tucker reads Trump's post and he
really doesn't like the praise be to
Allah part.
Just watch. Praise be to Allah.
So, obviously, you're mocking the
religion of Iran.
Okay.
If you seek a religious war,
that's a good idea.
To be fair, Iranian leaders view this as
a religious war. So, if you know they
view this as a religious war, you may
want to mock their religion during the
war. But, you could argue that either
way. Watch what Tucker says next.
But, by the way, no decent person mocks
other people's religion. Say what now?
No decent person mocks other people's
religion. But, what if it's Talmudic
Judaism, Tucker?
No decent person mocks other people's
religion. Now, I'm obviously not a
decent person, according to Tucker
Carlson, because I mock Islam all the
time.
Most of my friends are either critics of
Islam or ex-Muslims who mock Islam.
Ex-Muslims are under a death sentence
for refusing to mindlessly obey the
ramblings of an illiterate 7th-century
Arabian caravan robber.
But, they're not allowed to mock the
religion that calls for their public
executions.
They wouldn't be decent people if they
mocked the religion that calls for their
deaths, according to Tucker Carlson.
Plenty of prophets in the Bible, and
even God himself in the Bible, mock
other religions. So, none of them are
decent, according to world-renowned
scholar of religions, Tucker Carlson.
But, we'll ignore all of that for now,
because there's a huge hypocrisy we need
to consider.
Muslims and their allies have been
celebrating and praising Tucker's claim
that no decent person mocks other
people's religion.
The Muslim mom posted, "Tucker Carlson
goes off on Donald Trump for mocking
Islam."
Mehdi Hasan,
"Okay, this is actually pretty good. Not
just because he is pushing back against
the right-wing mockery of Islam, but for
the first time, Tucker is breaking with
Trump, directly criticizing him. That's
bold given his base.
CHUNK YOGURT PEOPLE TELL ME I have TO
[screaming] HATE TUCKER CARLSON, BUT NO
one in the mainstream media would ever
say that to us. No president should mock
Islam. They asked me and MUSLIMS TO HELP
ISRAEL. Am I supposed to disagree with
this? WE ARE NOT A THEOCRACY, AND GOD
WILLING, WE NEVER WILL BE.
SAMIRA MUNSHI Powerful As a Muslim, I
will never mock another faith, and as an
American, I expect that of my leaders as
well.
Good snooze network Tucker Carlson No
president should mock Islam. That's not
your job. This is not a theocracy. We
don't go to war with other theocracies
to find out which one is more effective.
We are not a theocracy, and God willing,
we never will be.
Khadija Siddiqi No decent person mocks
other people's religion, said Tucker.
Finally, someone prominent from the
Republican side is saying what many
Muslims have been pointing out. Mocking
other people's religion isn't right.
It's time to stop the bigotry.
Well, there you have it. Muslims agree
that no decent person would ever mock
other people's religion.
But do Muslims actually believe that? Or
are they just pretending to believe it
in order to convince gullible people not
to mock Islam?
If Muslims actually believe that no
decent person would ever mock other
people's religion, they've got a serious
problem because Muhammad and his
companions mocked other people's
religion.
In Sahih Bukhari 2478, Muhammad conquers
Mecca, which was filled with
polytheists. What did Muhammad do?
The prophet entered Mecca and at that
time there were 360
idols around the Kaaba.
He started stabbing the idols with a
stick he had in his hand and reciting,
"Truth Islam has come and falsehood,
disbelief, has vanished."
Muhammad went around stabbing the idols
of the polytheists. He stabbed them
to show his contempt for them.
He stabbed idols to insult and mock and
degrade them.
This means that according to Tucker
Carlson, Muhammad was not a decent
person because
no decent person mocks other people's
religion. And according to all the
Muslims who praised and celebrated and
agreed with Tucker Carlson, Muhammad was
not a decent person.
And neither were Muhammad's companions.
In the history of al-Tabari, one of the
polytheists tells Muhammad that if he
loses the war against his own tribe, his
followers will abandon him.
Abu Bakr, Muhammad's closest companion
and the first of the rightly guided
caliphs, replies to the polytheist in
the presence of Muhammad,
"Go suck the clitoris of al-Lat. Would
we flee and leave him?"
Al-Lat was a goddess that this man
worshipped.
Abu Bakr told him to go perform oral sex
on his goddess.
So, according to Tucker Carlson and
everyone who agreed with him, Abu Bakr
wasn't a decent person.
How did such an indecent person become
the first of the rightly guided caliphs?
Always strange seeing people so
desperate to protect Islam from
criticism that they end up condemning
Muhammad and his companions.
Well, let's try to understand why no
decent person would ever mock Islam.
Back to Tucker.
But by the way, no decent person mocks
other people's religions. You may have a
problem with the theology, presumably
you do if it's not your religion, and
you can explain what that is.
But to mock other people's faith is to
mock the idea of faith itself, and we
should never mock that. To mock other
people's faith
is to mock the idea of faith itself?
But you mock other people's faith is to
mock the idea of faith itself. Ladies
and gentlemen,
beware of claims that are meant to sound
profound, but are profoundly idiotic.
Do Muslims agree that by mocking the
faith of the polytheists, Muhammad and
his companions were mocking the idea of
faith itself, and therefore even the
faith of Muslims?
Do you believe that, Muslims?
A bunch of you shared the clip and
agreed with it.
So Muhammad and his companions were
mocking the idea of faith, and thus
mocking their own faith, right?
To mock someone's faith is to mock the
idea of faith itself. That is one of the
most insanely stupid claims ever made by
anyone.
Think of a few parallels.
To mock a person's political views is to
mock the idea of politics itself.
To mock a person's morality is to mock
the idea of morality itself.
To mock a person's claims about history
or science is to mock the very idea of
history or science. Do you understand
how utterly absurd and foolish Tucker's
proclamation is?
And no, Tucker, by calling your
proclamation absurd and foolish, I'm not
attacking the idea of proclamations.
Guess what, Tucker? I can say you're a
without saying that all people are
morons, or that the idea of people is
moronic. I can say your dog is ugly
without saying that all dogs are ugly or
that the idea of dogs is ugly. I can say
that your reasoning is terrible without
saying that the idea of reason is
terrible.
If you have to invent rules that make no
sense whatsoever to any sane person in
order to shield Islam from criticism,
maybe you shouldn't be shielding Islam
from criticism.
But to mock other people's faith is to
mock the idea of faith itself, and we
should never mock that. Because at its
core is the acknowledgement that we are
not in charge of the universe. We did
not build it. We won't be here at the
end of it. We can destroy life. We
cannot create it because we are not God.
So, if I mock Islam, then I'm mocking
the idea of faith itself, and I'm
somehow claiming that I'm in charge of
the universe.
>> [snorts]
>> Are you getting this?
The message of all faith
at the biggest picture level is the
message in our Bible. The same Bible
that regularly mocks other people's
religions?
The message of all faith
at the biggest picture level is the
message in our Bible, which is you are
not God. And only if you think you are,
do you talk this way.
You only mock Islam if you think you're
God.
Why would Tucker Carlson be so desperate
to protect Islam that he's willing to
create out of nothing an entire moral
framework? Almost like he thinks he's
God.
If Tucker thinks he can make up rules
that all decent people must follow, that
would seem like a claim to be God far
more than mocking the gibberish spouted
by the most obvious false prophet in
history is a claim to be God.
Tell me,
why wouldn't I mock Muhammad for saying
things like
"The eyes are the leather strap of the
anus,
so one who sleeps should perform
ablution."
Whether Tucker likes it or not, it is
entirely appropriate to mock Muhammad's
claim that the eyes are the leather
strap of the anus. Especially when the
same guy who said the eyes are the
leather strap of the anus also commanded
his followers to violently subjugate the
entire world.
And no amount of Tucker-speak is ever
going to convince me that false prophets
shouldn't be mocked.
But it gets worse,
because Tucker goes on to tell his
viewers
that the only acceptable and appropriate
Christian response to Islamic aggression
is to submit to it.
I kid you not.
We'll discuss it next time
on the Tucker Carlson is becoming an
Antichrist Chronicles.
You've got to try that.
>> [music]
>> You've got to try that. You've got to
try that.
You just might find you You've got to
[music] try that.
You've got to try that.
You just might find you This is a
powerful religion. There's a reason to
it. Yeah? Yeah? Yeah?